Leon Edwards Kumar Usman watching it the
first round I give to Leon Lynn looked
phenomenal round two I thought Camaro
did more so I give to Camaro round three
I would have gave to Kamara as well and
then get the point taken for the defense
grab so then that would be a 10-8 round
so that would mean Camaro up three
rounds to one at this point round four
you would give to Leon round five you
would give to Leon I'd assume it's a
draw then when you go back you look at
the copy strike numbers you watch the
fight again I can see how they would
give round one round two to Leon round
three
he landed more shots so if you give it
to him that'd be a nine nine round right
and then round four round five would be
Leon I mean one judge had to draw the
rest had it scored like that